sí Países Bajos es el primer equipo
clasificado de los cuartos de final La
naranja mecánica que se impuso por tres
a uno a Estados Unidos con más oficio
que buen fútbol hoy la podríamos Llamar
la naranja oficiosa se impusieron un
equipo de Estados Unidos muy joven Que
pagó precisamente esa falta de
experiencia aquí en el estadio jalifa
los estadounidenses que comenzaron ya
perdiendo muy temprano en el partido al
minuto 10 memphises depay había
adelantado a los enerlandeses de Pipe
que repetía como inicialista por segunda
ocasión en esta copa mundo y fue uno de
los mejores de los suyos Por parte de
Estados Unidos cerviño desde el lateral
del Milan iba a tener en sus botas el
uno a uno parcial es un empate que
terminó un desacierto del lateral
estadounidense y pasamos justo antes del
Descanso justo en las jugadas siguiente
al dos a cero para los neerlandeses que
marcó el jugador Danny se llegó a la
segunda parte mientras los aficionados
neerlandeses siguen Aquí festejando ese
triunfo llegamos Entonces a esa segunda
parte en la que el combinado de las
barras y las estrellas acudió al
banquillo entró
fue precisamente wright el que puso el
2-1 parcial que daba ilusiones a los
norteamericanos pero Se repitió el papel
de nuevo en la jugada casi que siguiente
fue Dance quien culminó a la perfección
una jugada colectiva Y puso el tres a
uno asistencia Por cierto les dan eblin
otro de los buenos jugadores que tuvimos
hoy otro de los jugadores que realizó un
buen papel La naranja mecánica que
espera ahora rival en esos cuartos de
final Como curiosidad tanto Estados
Unidos como Países Bajos realizaron la
misma cantidad de disparos a Puerta 6
por cada uno de ellos